ah
hola soy atea licastro y suicidio y
fundadora de option
desde muy pequeña me interesó la ciencia
me parecía sorprendente y como la
inventiva de las personas y la capacidad
de entendimiento de la naturaleza habían
logrado crear el mundo del que vivimos
el avance científico y tecnológico ha
significado el progreso de la
civilización desde por ejemplo la
creación de la rueda hasta el
descubrimiento del radio fueron
utilizados con fines muy positivos sin
embargo las innovaciones realizadas con
esta tecnología también fueron mutando
más aspecto letal con la creación de
armamento y material destructivo en
términos de progreso vemos como una
constante en los países dominantes el
interés por reforzar en su nivel más
básico la educación y en lo más visible
y utilitario la innovación pero estos
avances un proceso complejo que tiene
como intermedio el impulso del
desarrollo científico que se gesta por
ejemplo en universidades e institutos en
estos espacios la innovación es donde
crea el mundo del mañana en nuestros
países latinoamericanos la investigación
e innovación científica y tecnológica
viene
o avanzando muy lentamente es por eso
que ustedes como estudiantes deben ser
los hacedores de las nuevas tecnologías
de investigaciones que generen cambios
que signifiquen avances importantes para
nuestros países en este momento de caos
político social e ambiental económico y
sanitario debido a la pandemia la única
esperanza que tenemos es apostar por los
cerebros por esas mentes brillantes que
conocen de primera mano los problemas
que tenemos como comunidad y los
desafíos a los que nos enfrentamos como
ciudadanos debemos dejar de pensar en
que la solución va a venir de afuera
tenemos que empezar a mirar adentro
nuestro mayor capital en este momento
son las personas tenemos que entender
que si tomamos una solución que ha sido
creada para otro país y tratamos de
adaptarla para nuestro país jamás va a
cubrir al 100% nuestras necesidades lo
que tenemos que hacer es empezar a crear
nuestras propias soluciones crear
nuestra tecnología porque inventiva no
nos falta por ejemplo en 2019 viaje a
eeuu porque me seleccionaron en el de my
team y ahí conocí personas increíbles
con todo tipo de proyectos interesantes
que iban desde hacer bio arte con
bacterias hasta proyectos para
democratizar la ciencia a hacer que la
ciencia esté al alcance de todos y este
tipo de proyectos iban de la mano con
que ellos querían hacer equipos de bajo
costo y de código libre para que estos
equipos sean accesibles para todas las
personas lo que significaba que
cualquier persona en cualquier parte del
mundo podría replicarlo nada más con la
con el código en ese momento me puse a
pensar que muchas veces en mi
universidad cuando no contábamos con
algún tipo de equipo ya sea por ejemplo
una incubadora o un biorreactor un
fotobiorreactor
nosotros mismos lo teníamos que fabricar
pero era por necesidad no porque
queríamos ser parte de un movimiento bio
hacker o algo similar y conversando con
otros colegas latinos me comentaban que
en sus universidades o institutos les
pasaba lo mismo
así que en retrospectiva nosotros los
latinos somos los que hemos inventado el
bio jaque y el código abierto mucho
antes de que siquiera se llame así o que
se ponga de moda eso demuestra que
tenemos una capacidad de invención y
solución de problemas increíble ahora
imagínense lo que podríamos hacer con
más recursos si lo que hacemos ahora lo
hacemos por necesidad
imagínense si hasta dónde llegaríamos si
todos nos ponemos a crear cosas para
poder lograr tener un mundo mejor
y yo creo que ahora esto está en
nuestras manos en las manos de toda
nuestra generación por ejemplo antes y
durante la pandemia tuvimos estallidos
sociales en muchos países
latinoamericanos toda nuestra generación
salió a protestar por lo que creía justo
no protestamos por un partido político o
por una ideología en específico
simplemente nos dimos cuenta que algo
estaba mal y todos salimos a protestar
para cambiarlo por ejemplo nadie nos
organizó a todos juntos por ejemplo en
chile empezaron los estallidos sociales
luego en perú y muchas de las
experiencias que tuvieron nuestros
hermanos chilenos por ejemplo para
desactivar bombas lacrimógenas y todo
eso la subían a redes acá la gente
aprendía y simplemente nos organizamos
todos fue algo más de que la gente
aprendía por internet aprendí a los
paramédicos los que estaban estudiando
medicina o enfermería y carreras
similares se ofrecieron de voluntario
libremente y salían a las calles a
defender a proteger a las personas que
estaban heridas la gente que salía a
protestar
compartía las experiencias con personas
de otros países para que también puedan
protegerse de la misma manera entonces
yo creo que como generación ya tenemos
una colaboración conjunta como
generación ya hablamos de algo más que
que sea tan simple como que o eres de
derecha o de izquierda y yo creo que
esas cosas
ya no cuentan en nuestra generación yo
creo que es algo más que es lo que
parece justo y qué es lo que no yo creo
que de todo eso nos llevamos una lección
bastante importante
que todos nosotros estábamos de acuerdo
en una sola cosa el mundo que nos están
dejando nuestros padres ese mundo que ya
lo tenemos heredado no es el mundo que
queremos
estamos luchando para cambiar ese mundo
entonces ustedes de qué lado están van a
estar del lado que se queda sentado
mirando como todo pasa o son de las
personas que van a luchar por moldear el
mundo hasta convertirlo en algo que
realmente quieren heredar después a sus
hijos este grito de guerra debe
significar más que sólo cambios sociales
es momento de levantarnos como
generación y mostrar el mundo que
podemos mejorarlo científica y
tecnológicamente podemos hacer potencias
sólo debemos enfocar todo nuestro
potencial en crear el mundo en el que
queremos vivir